la cigale ayant chanté tout l'été vous
connaissez la fable ce n'est pas une
légende
il y en a plein autour de moi j'adore
les entendre chanter pendant les
vacances je vous envoie une carte en
france on les trouve essentiellement
autour de la méditerranée on en a
comptabilisé une dizaine d'espèces
différentes chez les cigales
c'est monsieur qui chante je vais vous
montrer
[Musique]
voici le chanteur et sa groupie madame
et monsieur ils sont à la même échelle
comme vous pouvez le constater il ya
très peu de différences entre les deux
pas de dimorphisme sexuel comme disent
les biologistes peut-être aurez-vous
simplement remarqué la présence de ce
petit conduit chez la femelle l'ovi
poesy terre qui lui permet de déposer
ses oeufs alors les cigales chantent
depuis très longtemps
les dinosaures faisait déjà la sieste au
chant des cigales
[Musique]
ce sont des maquettes dans la nature
les cigales sont beaucoup plus discrète
on va essayer d'en trouver une
on les entend bien mais elles ne sont
pas faciles à dénicher
elles se confondent avec les corps des
arbres en fait il faut y aller à
l'oreille par la tiens en voilà une
les mâles chantent pour attirer les
femelles et se reproduire
eh ben dites donc mesdames vous avez le
choix allez allons voir de quoi sont
équipés ces messieurs je parle des
organes dédié au chant bien entendu j'ai
eu une révélation à faire la cigale ne
chante pas elle joue d'un instrument des
cymbales on dit d'ailleurs qu'elle
symbolise des cymbales pas tout à fait
comme celle ci elles ont la forme d'une
amende ou d'un ballon de rugby elles
sont constituées d'une membrane
renforcée par des petites côtes
légèrement incurvé les instruments se
trouve sous les ailes au niveau de la
dernière pattes une de chaque côté
alors la cigale n'en joue pas en les
frappant l'une contre l'autre avec ses
petites pattes pour produire un son
elles contractent le muscle situé juste
au dessus
la cymbale ce d'efforts chaque côté ce
redressement après l'autre et ça claque
un peu comme cette pince à cheveux quand
le muscles se relâchent les côtes
reprennent une à une
leur place initiale et s'attaque à
nouveau tout cela va très vite quand la
cigale chante le muscle se contracte une
centaine de fois par seconde
le son est ensuite recueillis dans une
cavité creuse situé au niveau de
l'abdomen qui agit comme la caisse de
résonance d'une guitare ou d'un ukulélé
ce qui permet d'amplifier le soin la
cigale l insecte le plus bruyant de la
planète le record a été enregistré avec
une filiale australienne 120 décibels ce
qui correspond au bruit d'un avion au
décollage
heureusement une hausse égale
métropolitaine sont moins brillantes 80
décibels ce qui correspond quand même au
bruit d'un aspirateur
évidemment c'est moins sympa pour faire
la sieste
et là tout le monde se pose la même
question comment font-elles pour ne pas
devenir sourde comme nous les cigales
sont équipés d'un tympan une membrane
qui se met à vibrer quand une onde
sonore la rencontre c'est ce qui fait
sauter les grains de sel quand la cigale
chante elle relâche l'attention de son
tympan
celui ci ne peut plus vibrer
elles seront fournis en quelque sorte
elle ne s'écoute pas chanter elle mais
pourquoi nos champs tels que pendant
l'été et uniquement la journée
[Musique]
vous vous souvenez du must see actions
des cymbales il ne peut se contracter
que s'il est assez souple et pour cela
il faut de la chaleur
au moins vingt degrés jusqu'à 24 degrés
pour les cigales les plus grosses dans
l'été s'achève et quand la nuit tombe
la température est trop basse
leurs muscles sont trop raide elles ne
peuvent plus chanter mais ce n'est pas
tout si elle ne chante plus à l'arrivée
de l'automne c'est parce que leur vie
d'adulte est très courte
la cia y passe le plus clair de sa vie
sous nos pieds dans le sol au stade
larvaire cette période dure de deux à
cinq ans pour les cigales de nos régions
le moment venu
au printemps elle sort de terre il
grimpe sur un tronc et entame sa
dernière muet laisse derrière elle une
belle et xvi puis s'envole vers la cime
des arbres pour se reproduire
c'est à ce moment que les mâles chantent
une fois féconder les femelles
redescendre sur le plancher des vaches
puis elles pondent sur une tige ou une
écorce
ensuite elle meurt je sais c'est triste
mais au bout de quelques semaines les
oeufs éclosent et des centaines de
larves tombe au sol et s'enfuit dans la
terre c'est l'histoire de la vie
le cycle éternel ça m'a fait quelque
chose ça autrement dit une cigale
adultes comme celle ci ne vit pas plus
de trois à quatre semaines
désolé monsieur de la fontaine mais
quand la bise fut venue
la cigale à la pas crier famine chez la
fourmi sa voisine
ça c'est une légende que faisiez-vous au
temps chaud
vous chantiez et bien dormi
[Musique]
si vous avez aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez
pas à laisser un pouce bleus et à vous
abonner très bonne fin de vacances à
toutes et à tous
je vous retrouve dans deux semaines à la
rentrée
[Musique]